Posit Cloud is an online platform where
you can easily do and share data work
with just a few clicks. We recently added
a new feature called Data Connections
which lets you securely store database
credentials and share them across data
projects and among your collaborators.
In this tutorial, we will demonstrate how
to achieve this by using a publicly
available Postgres database. Let's get
started.
The first thing we're going to do is
create a new space. You can find this in
the upper left-hand nav bar.
Let's go ahead and create a new space,
calling it RNA Project.
This will create a new space for us to
do work and invite others to collaborate.
You can start a new project, but before
we do that, let's go to Data.
This is where you're going to add your
new data connection.
Click on add connection
and we're going to make a new connection
name.
Let's type in RNAcentral,
which is going to be a Postgres database.
These credentials are publicly available
and linked to in the description.
Our user is going to be reader.
I'll paste in the password, which you can
find online,
and the server,
finally, we're going to go ahead and put
in our port number
and our database name.
Once we do this, we're going to click on
OK,
the database connection is going to be
stored and saved
and we're going to be able to use this
in projects, so let's go back to content
and now let's create a new
RStudio IDE project from the drop-down.
While the project is loading, let's
rename it
RNA Analysis.
Once Posit Cloud is done spinning up
your individualized IDE,
we're going to be able to access that
database connection that we just defined
so if you look in the upper right-hand
of the IDE,
and move to the connections tab,
we're going to start a new connection
and there it is: the database connection
we just saved, RNAcentral.
Clicking on this is going to show you a
code snippet, which includes all of the
information, including the encrypted
password.
Let's use a new R script
to connect to
and analyze the data.
The first thing this is going to do is
load in a necessary package, and while
it's doing that let's name the R script
rna_explorer.
From here, we can then load the library
that we need
and the DBI library, and create our first
connection.
The connection has been made, and you can
see in the connections tab all of the
schemas available for this database
connection.
Before we make our first query, let's
bring in two libraries:
dplyr and dbplyr.
Now, neither of these have been installed
yet
but the IDE will remind me of this and
we can install right away.
Once these packages are ready, we're
going to go ahead and make a query
and we can do this by using the con
variable that has stored the connection
that is still live.
Let's go ahead and create a new variable
named results.
From here,
we're going to call the connection
and then bring in the specific schema
name and table that we're interested in.
For now,
we're just going to go ahead and get the
top 200 results within this table.
When I run this,
we went to the database, we got all the
information on the top 200 rows, and now
we can see this in the environment. We
have both our connection still
and results data frame, which has 200
observations.
If we take a quick peek,
we can see the type of information that
is stored
and there seems to be an integer
variable length
for each of the observations.
We can quickly turn this into a
histogram
to see what we're working with.
Some observations are in the 0 to 500
range
while many are up around 1200 or above.
The best part is if you create a new
project, you'll be able to access the
same database connection,
and if you change the information from
your connection, it'll automatically
update in new and existing projects once
it's relaunched.
I hope you enjoyed learning about the
new data connections feature in Posit
Cloud.
You can visit posit.cloud to create a
free account, connect to your databases,
and begin exploring.